hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trendsenses.com
so
i hope you guys had a good weekend i had
it's monday right now um
markets dropped heavily on friday so
this morning we opened lower then we had
some rebounds so let's analyze
everything guys let's see what we had
what kind of information we can get from
the press action today on amc on gme on
triple q on oil uh i'm also going to
talk about the us 10 new yield i told
you guys this is very important to keep
an eye on and i want to show you quickly
something about bitcoin so let's get
into it
i guess as usual we're gonna start with
amc
so
time frame
bam bam bam
let me sum up the situation here
so
uh we are looking for a reversal
uh signal
that could be signaling the next very
strong move up why would we potentially
have a very strong move up now because
we already had a very strong move up
very recently which was the first wave
so now we are in a second wave once
again this second wave is not usual it's
a bit deep for a second wave because
second waves usually don't go below the
61.8 percent fib ratio here we are below
the
78.6 so
even if we have a very nice bullish
signal here
we would need to see a lot of bullish
price action you know around the 21 26
level uh to confirm we might be in the
third wave and not uh just in a reversal
but whatever let's first find this
reversal then we're gonna discuss how
high it can go uh so to find a reversal
as usual guys we're looking for reversal
signals i mean reversal signs uh so
reversal signs can come from momentum
they can come from the volume they can
come from volatility um volatility is
the amplitude of the moves and here like
i showed you that before we're gonna
zoom in go on a first time frame because
um if you want to have information about
you know a third wave that is on a daily
time frame you need to zoom in to find
some shorter term signals so we're going
to use the first time frame and the
hourly time frame and here
i showed you in my last video that we
had the buddhist divergence once again
momentum going higher price action going
lower and we had a breakout but the
breakout
on low volume uh once again to find the
breakout you first need to find the
trend line and trendline is something
you're gonna find whenever you have
enough reactions in the recent past here
had one two three reactions so this was
a trendline that was good for me to use
but the volume was very weak uh during
the breakout
which was still good uh news for
reversal but it was um an easy target
for bez all right so here bears attacked
and uh we dropped uh more so right now
what do we have guys we have a new
bullish divergence all right still on
the first time frame
as you can see but now the bullish
divergence is bigger right it's between
here and here right between april 22nd
and
uh sorry
april 12th and april 22nd so 10 days
bullish divergence do we have it on the
macd we do have it on the macd all right
so we have a
double
bullish divergence so
as you guys know whenever we find a
buddhist divergence we then need to
combine it with another
um
bullish signal that could be a
candlestick pattern that could be a
breakout that could be a moving average
crossover that could be an rsi above 50
if you're using the right time frame it
can be a lot of things if you want to
know everything guys you can get the
course once again you have some discord
memberships included if you take it
right now link in the description of
this video but uh the best signal we can
find is a breakout and as you can see
this breakout has not hold all right we
went above we got rejected so we don't
need this channel anymore we don't need
this breakout we don't need that all
right and now we need to find another
trend line so we don't have it for now
so i'm gonna i'm doing it live with you
guys
uh bam bam bam first logarithmic scale
that's good okay
i don't need that and
to find the trend line that we're going
to use for the next breakout once again
we need to find a trendline that is
taking into account the whole bullish
divergence all right so it's something
that is going to start here and going to
end up here right between here and here
something like that so i don't know
exactly where to put it because i don't
have enough reactions in the recent past
but i can already see i hope you guys
see well that this one is not very good
because i have only two reactions so i
don't like this trend line
i'm going to try to find another one and
i can already see that here we have some
kind of a cluster right that is a
consolidation that is taking place so
this is going to guide me for my trend
line i don't like this one i rather
going to start with something that is
like that and here you see
so it's not perfect but here i have one
reaction
and if i do it like that
it's not too bad right it's not too bad
because i have one
two not really two three
and not really four all right so i have
three plus one i guess
okay two three reactions i mean after
the trendline but i mean in terms of
reactions on the trend and i have one
two
okay i don't count this one three and i
don't really three point five right so
it's not a very good trend line let's be
honest but it's the best i have and i
have the twenty uh period moving average
on the first time frame that is coming
here so for now i'm not sure at all this
trendline is good and i'm gonna know if
it's good or not of course without
guarantee but i'm gonna have more
information about
if this trendline was used by bears or
not whenever we're gonna go through it
if we do because i'm gonna check the
volume if we go through it without
volume it means that there were not a
lot of bears gathered here and it's
gonna give us another weak signal that
is likely to be sold to be attacked so
for now this is what we are looking for
so the level is roughly around 17.2
um so let's see if we're able to go
through 17.2 with volume this would be
looking very good for potential third
wave that we would need to analyze uh
whatever is going to start and once
again to analyze a third wave we're
gonna pay attention a lot to the volume
and the amplitude of the moves the
volatility uh by the way guys one thing
i wanted to ask you today because i'm
not asking you things very often as you
guys know um um you know on different
projects um
you know my main project is of course my
course my discord this is you know what
i'm doing since i quit my job i do all
this analysis with you guys
um you know um
i'm basically very trading oriented but
i'm starting as well to uh create my
nfts you know the crypto booze the
website is going to come soon i'm going
to share it with you
uh and for the crypto bus project to
work i'm making uh i will make some
collabs later the video i posted
yesterday about scalians i was like i
said this was not a collab this was the
project of a friend of mine uh that is
gonna help me here and what i need you
guys is to go on this video i put the
link in the description of this video
it's gonna take one second guys just
click on it and like it all right it's
important for me because other products
are gonna check if if when i do a video
about another nft project if i have
engagement so
you don't need to watch the full video
if you're not interested but please give
me this view give me this like so that i
can use that and see and go to other
projects and just say hey look guys
collaborate with me because i'm going to
talk about your project and my community
is gonna maybe join your project so uh
once again uh it's not important guys if
you are not interested in that just give
me this view give me this like it's
gonna be
very good for my nft crypto bull
products i'm asking you this yes once
again i don't i don't ask you many
things uh but please do that and once
again it's good for the crypto bull
project which means it's good for you
guys because as uh trading sciences
members uh you can access the early bull
roll very easily
there are not that many but for now we
still have so for all of you of you guys
who want to be there and get your crypto
bull at a very good price you can have
it right now just join the crypto booth
server
you can find the link in any video i
post
and if i manage to make this project uh
moon which i will guess because uh i'm
not gonna explain everything here but
we're gonna do something amazing those
who entered early are gonna make huge
profits so you guys if you want to be
part of it
so thank you very much guys and and uh
yeah thanks thanks a lot for helping me
on that so let's get back to uh
amc we're looking for this breakup guys
and we are looking once again
for
as you can see
um there is another sign we can pay
attention to is what we have on the rsi
for now we're having an rsm the first
time frame at 40 and we can see that we
got rejected at 50 so you know once
again the 50 level is often as you can
see a level where we are where we have
sometimes a rejection sometimes a
support so we we got rejected here
um
and we've never been above 50 on the
forest time frame uh since we started to
plunge so if we are above 50 it's going
to be something new that we didn't
manage to do here so i would say that
for our next breakout to be really good
quality we would need this breakout to
happen with volume and with the 4 hours
rsi above 15. so we're going to monitor
that and if we have that it will be
looking very good
and then i can quickly sum up the
situation once this happens guys are we
gonna once again need to really fight
this bearish momentum that uh is
happening for the past month uh by
you know
really breaking out above the major
resistances and get close to this 26
level i would say that if we stay below
21 we are likely to just you know move
sideways here but if we manage to go
above that then we are in an area where
everything can happen and once again as
you guys know this will be related very
much to what is happening on the rest of
the market now let's do dme today so amc
is today up one percent gm is losing 1.5
the global market is rather flattish so
um
i mean it's a quiet day
uh i have some interesting things to
show you later but today i mean this we
don't have many information much
information here uh so jme
closed uh the day
on friday down 2.3 percent uh we broke
out below the 141.5 level that i told
you guys is important we are now in this
area
where i don't see any support before 130
so
my take is that at some point either we
come back to 141.5 and then we drop or
we drop first and then we go there but
at some point we need i think to find
some support here
um
let's zoom in a little bit and do the
same exercise as we did for amc what is
the momentum telling us so here you can
see that we don't have this bullish
divergence taking place so for the first
time amc is having better signals than
gme but you guys know why is because
jimmy is stronger
i mean in the whole correction that we
had for the past month
um and jimmy is amc is still trading at
a discount compared to gme so maybe amc
bottomed before and now maybe jimmy is
going to catch up i don't know but what
i see is that the momentum is still
dropping on the first time frame on gme
when while it is going up on amc so
so i'm not sure exactly what it means in
terms of
uh targets for the coming week or two
weeks but
uh it means to me that we have a little
bit more downside to come on gme
apparently so let's find out
um
we can of course do the same
uh trend lines as we did for amc but
here it makes less sense because we
don't have the buddhist divergence so
once again a breakout without a british
divergence is totally fine if we have
the volume increase
and the breakout happens after
consolidation on low volume then we we
good but here
you know i don't really know where to
put this trend line
i'm here using the logarithmic scale let
me go on the regular scale because once
again you guys know that on gme we are
using the regular scale and as you can
see guys
uh it's not by
uh
why did it move up i was good like that
okay
okay the streamline is not very well
placed but as you can see it's giving me
here nice reactions so let's place it
properly
okay
yeah it's pretty pretty good
and it's giving me nice reactions i mean
we are sliding on the streamline so you
know this is the problem with um
support levels that are decreasing all
right uh downward sloping trend line
like that it's because
um
we have support but every day the
support is lower so it's not you know
the kind of supports we like to have my
take is here that we're gonna go 230
find more supports once again we have
room guys in gme because gme is still
hovering around the 50 feet ratio of the
first move up so we are still here
bullish guys on the long term
uh we still have a little bit more
downside that could happen but it would
be totally fine at 130
uh it would be a nice buying opportunity
um
i'm taking for more support coming here
bam where the 50-day moving average
coming here it's not a very strong one
but as you can see
here the 50-day moving average was
acting very well as resistance
here so
i mean
it's it might very well act as support
as well whenever something has worked in
the recent past it means that a lot of
traders are using it and that it's more
likely to work again in uh the future so
here um you know have a double support
at 130. so once again this scenario
makes sense to me and once again the
61.8 fib ratio is at 124 right so it's
slightly below that i would have liked
to have it uh in the same area as well
it's a little bit lower so let's see
let's see what happens guys here but
support is quite close
uh and for boost to take back control i
mean
for now it's not clear i don't have any
trend line the best thing i have is that
141.5 is resistant so first if we manage
to close above that it would be great we
would be back in this kind of neutral
area and above 152 we gonna start to be
bullish so let's analyze all of that
when it happens now triple two yes i'm
gonna be quick on this uh because it's
flat today nothing much happening um
i can share my view again guys i'm still
a little bit in this uh you know
situation where we still have an upside
scenario that can happen but let's be
honest the probability that happens
right now is quite low to me
uh it's 20
but i could even give it uh
15 because the 20 probability was
estimated when we were here so basically
just after i got stopped at 339.5
i told you guys i posted this in my
discord that we are likely to drop i
posted an alert with a level to sell at
338.5
uh i think i posted 338 we didn't reach
that level so um
so unfortunately this trade didn't work
i mean we didn't make money but we
didn't lose money but we didn't make
money either
uh right now i think that we're gonna
keep dropping
and find probably more support at 318
before uh
you know getting back acting higher and
maybe here we're gonna have this
opportunity that we missed here to take
a bearish position so let's find out
um it's also possible that we come here
just you know i think that we're gonna
have a rebound it's very likely i'm here
gonna take a bullish position
uh because
whenever a support has not been touched
for quite some time the first time it
usually gives a nice reaction but then
we can get back to it quickly so
let's see and this is another scenario
that we considered a little bit here a
little bit like we did here but that
this time we break it right so this is
another situation if this happens then
we can again um either build a bearish
position here but this one would be much
riskier
so here in this situation i would
personally wait um
and build a long position only here guys
much lower because
this is a take profit area for those who
have a short position so i have some
short position but it's not
as big as i wish it could be
because i couldn't sell here as i wanted
to
um
so i won't be taking profit here or
maybe i will take just a little bit of
profits and to be very honest guys it's
going to depend a lot on what's going to
happen on the u.s 10 year yield i showed
you guys that before for those who have
not seen this video go check my yes the
video i posted on saturday because i'm
explaining quite well why the u.s
10-year yield is important why is it an
indicator that a lot of traders are
watching and why
we don't want to see this breakout that
is happening uh be confirmed
all right so basically the only thing i
can tell you here to make it quick is
that
we are at a very dangerous level um
above 2.93 i can tell you guys that a
big uh a lot of big asset managers are
gonna start to offload uh the equity
market and we're gonna probably uh see a
strong sell-off happening so uh we are
monitoring this level
uh
and once again we have here the price
action coming here and breaking out
you know but without any consolidation
so usually this kind of breakout
are rejected so if this happens we will
probably have a nice rebound on the
equity market
uh on the other hand if we confirm with
a weekly close this is the weekly
diaphragm so if this friday all right so
in four days we close above
two point
eighty five so right now we are below
that as you can see we're at 2.8 so this
is good that's why the equity market
today is making a pose
uh but if we close next friday at 2.93
guys
whatever the price i think i would be
selling the market all right because
this would not be looking nice
but for now we are not here
uh so we're going to keep monitoring
that then oil guys
here so as you guys know i'm bullish on
oil since we have this breakout
uh today is not a good day again
for this position because it's losing
five percent
uh it's mostly due i think to what is
happening in china with the kovi that's
going to impact the global demands as
you guys know the community market is
very related to the growth of the
economy
so
you know it's also related to what is
happening in ukraine of course
but we are below 100 i told you guys
that below 100 we are not looking so
good so right now
we are not looking so good
uh
i'm having cool options so you know i'm
just gonna lose my premium so you know a
few thousand dollars it's it's fine it's
not good of course but it's fine
uh we
so the trade was here to buy at 103
buy more at 100 and stop loss here so
here this position is out of the table
um right now on the weekly time frame we
still have some
nice support as you can see guys let me
redo this trendline properly
yeah we are below this trend line all
right so here we don't have any support
anymore that's why the 100 level was
very important to me
uh bam bam bam
and right now the next support is
at
93 all right we see we have the 20 day
moving average coming here as well
so
i mean above 93
i still feel like we are we have the
bullish momentum that is coming from
this long-term breakout but if we go
below 93
maybe it would mean that
you know the situation has changed and
that does break out even if it's a good
quality breakout as you can see
consolidation volume increase that maybe
it's not going to hold because once
again the community market is very very
related to macroeconomics and what is
happening in the rest of the world so
even if you have a nice technical signal
it can be rejected because the situation
is changing
so i'm still bullish on um on the
community market but we are getting
close to an area where maybe things will
change so we're gonna monitor that and
last but not least guys bitcoin
so i personally but i think i told you
that guys already i personally so here
are my three scenarios all right i had a
bullish scenario that is now off the
table bam
and as you can see i'm keeping the
scenarios we are exactly in the second
scenario for now which was that we go to
42 000 get rejected and then oscillate
and make new lows so i'm afraid this is
what is going to happen i personally
exit some of my bitcoin position at 42
and 42 500
i shared with you guys the straight in
discord of course and right now
um
[Music]
we are coming back to the 39
700 level
probably gonna get rejected here
i mean it's not clear as as you see
because in my scenario we were supposed
to go lower first then come back here i
mean let's be honest i really don't know
what um what what is going to happen
first are we first going to go to 37 or
42
uh are we gonna get rejected here i
don't know probably to be honest um
i'm checking the volume volume is still
low
so not we don't have much information
right guys so i mean here i'm pretty
neutral slightly bearish and i think
that uh
you know
we're gonna make some new lows at some
point i mean new laws maybe not but at
least come back to the low so 34
000 uh it seems inevitable to me uh
unless we have a strong rebound on the
global market
so let's find out bitcoin is going to go
together so once again the right
indicator to watch right now is this u.s
10-year yield that is going to impact
the global market that itself is going
to impact uh the crypto market
so that's it for today guys uh bam bam
bam i hope you enjoyed this video once
again don't forget guys uh to click on
this skylander video for me guys it's
something i'm asking you give me a like
give me a view we don't care if i mean
we don't you don't watch the full video
it's important that it looks good for
the project which is once again good for
you for the project but also good for
you if you want to be part of it so
that's it for today i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're going to be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys